my scooter no there how do the
rough in my day this is called class
Romesh ah my elegant Swan it just kind
of looks like a giant bandage beautiful
you let those pillows every gay man's
house ha ha ha ha that's the tea this
was my killer vacation Brock you look a
team the intern this on vacation because
she got fired for only pitching stories
about the deals the rest is still
unwritten that phase run was really
trying to undo my personality was
stripes I really thought I was onto
something with this outfit it's a lot of
family they need to just circumcise the
whole dress you look every one of Amy's
honest friends I'd like you're going to
your chairs in the husband's court case
ha ha
this is that slang for a bear Ginsburg
costume I wish I was Sarah Silverman's
robot if I thought this was a good idea
think of the other decisions I was
making to make relationships I love this
shirt I definitely feel like this is the
form for the waitresses at rainforest
cafe do you know what okay you are so
embarrassing
true it's just I feel like ever stand
like this I'm wearing this dress
this is forcing my body goes awesome
that's a boner chilly you look like the
creator of apple cider vinegar example
do not leave me alone with this second